- Chelsea, pleasure.
- So good to see you.
- Oh my gosh,
welcome back.
- This is great.
- I think you're just gonna be a regular.
Every time I'm in New York,
I'm just gonna beg you to
be in my show. (laughs)
- And I will gladly do it.
- We love you and thank you
for bringing Maven.
Maven, thank you for coming back.
- You're welcome.
- [Kelly] You look beautiful.
- I personally can't believe this.
I'm sitting next to the
secretary's daughter?
- [Kelly] Have y'all ever met?
- I've gotta go back and get my GED now.
(Kelly laughing)
I've got to!
- [Kelly] This is what-
- [Tracy] How'd this happen?
(Kelly laughs)
- So wait, last time you were here,
though you mentioned wanting Maven
to meet strong and powerful women.
So, well, here you go.
(all laugh)
So what are some questions you get
from younger women?
- Well, you know, one
of the things, Maven,
I'd love to ask you
because I get asked this a lot,
is when you were little, what did you-
- Even younger.
- Or even younger,
'cause you're growing up
as your dad knows, too fast, right?
What did you wanna be?
People asked me that all the time.
So if I ask you now, what do you wanna be?
- A Marine biologist.
- [Hillary] You wanna be a--
- (gasps) Gosh. That's what
my daughter wants to be.
- That's so cool.
And when you become a biologist,
what do you wanna study and learn about?
- Uh, the ocean?
- And is there a particular animal
that you really love in the ocean?
- Shark?
- Oh my gosh.
That's my daughter's favorite animal.
- [Kelly] Who doesn't?
- Oh my gosh, she--
- She has a 20,000 gallon shark tank
in our backyard.
- Oh my gosh.
- [Kelly] What?
- 14 or 15 sharks in there.
- [Chelsea] Seriously?
- Black tips, white tips or-
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Charlotte, turn off the television now.
- Charlotte.
(all laughing)
- Because we live in an apartment here
in New York City and we
do not have space for...
- She wanted it.
She wanted to study--
- [Kelly] That's incredible.
- So I put like eight tanks in the house.
Have the shark tank outside the house.
She has cone snail from Australia.
- [Hillary] Oh boy.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- Seven seas in the world.
And the cone snail is
the most dangerous thing
on the planet.
One cone snail
can kill a blue whale.
- [Kelly] So why not have 'em
in your house?
Cool.
- I'm so glad you've already
turned the television off.
- [Kelly] Who feeds them?
- No, No, um, I have a
team of people that come
and take care of her tanks every day.
- That's so cool.
Oh my God, you must love aquariums.
My kids love aquariums.
- Well, she's got her own in the backyard.
(all laugh)
- So some of us don't have huge aquariums
at our house.
We have to go to them.
I wanna ask you something though
because I heard that you have
like a favorite thing,
your definition of bravery, right?
What's your definition?
What do you think that is, to be brave?
- Mm something you do dangerous,
but you do it anyways.
- [Kelly] All right. I love that.
(audience clapping)
You know what, you only get one life.
Try. Yeah.
- You have to be brave.
She understands that, she knows that.
You have to do the things that-
it takes a lot of guts
to go for your dreams.
So I want her to know that you have to-
because one thing that stops us
in our lives is the word, if.
What if it doesn't work?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- No, you have to keep going.
- [Kelly] What if it does?
- If it doesn't work,
you do something else.
- Right.
- Yep.
- Were you always brave, like growing up?
Were you always--
- Well, I think we tried to be.
I mean, I think part of raising children,
is to give them both
roots and wings. Right?
You want them to have those standards.
You want them to have those values
but you also want them
to be able to take risks,
but you know, ones that are reasonable.
And so how do you inculcate that?
How do you talk about that?
And I think, talking about
how you encourage your
nine year old daughter
to frankly hang out with sharks,
which, you know,
I find pretty brave.
- Four eels.
- Um, yeah, no, I think you learn it.
And I think it comes from
primarily your family.
Sometimes people on the outside,
a teacher, a coach, a minister,
somebody else can help you
but it really does come from your family.
Yeah.
- I love that you just pointed out
something though as well.
Like not all of us, you know, are blessed
with great fathers.
Like not all of us are.
So what you just said like a village
can raise a kid.
Like I didn't have that experience.
But I didn't have that experience.
A lot of people don't
but what is important is
I had my pastor, Dr. Frankie Rainey.
He would cut out clippings
and send them to me
of like, "Great job on
this solo thing you did."
And, "Great job."
And I think that's important.
Like, even if you're not a parent,
you can still be a father figure
or a parental figure in some sense.
I love that you said that.
- A positive light,
a positive force.
- [Tracy] I had someone there for me.
- So, Tracy, you are on a comedy tour now.
So how'd you come up with the name,
"No Disrespect?"
- I'm gonna be saying things
I don't want anybody
taking in the wrong way.
(all laughing)
- It's a warning.
- Lemme tell you how I feel.
I'm a grown man.
I'm gonna speak on things.
- Bring football pads.
Too macho.
- Yeah. Don't take it in the wrong way.
So no disrespect before
we even get started.
No disrespect.
- But Tracy,
can I ask you because I've been following,
some comics are getting criticized
for saying something-
- [Kelly] A lot.
- Offends people and all of that.
- You want a war on free speech,
an attack on free speech.
- Yeah. But how do you think about that?
Cause I think people who
are in the public eye
should have the same right to free speech
as anybody else.
- [Tracy] Right.
To me, you got be funny.
- But you gotta be funny about it. Yeah.
- Cause anybody could do comedy.
Anybody could learn how to tell jokes,
but are you funny?
- Oh, see, that's like singers.
See, a lot of people can sing,
but they don't move you.
- But everybody can't sang.
(all laugh)
Lot of people can sing,
but everybody can't sang.
Aretha Franklin can sang.
- She was pretty good.
- Kelly, I was the kid
at their church choir.
They were always like, "You know,
we really appreciate Chelsea.
She's always on time."
(all laugh)
- Punctuality.
Also, maybe she should be
on the bells next year.
- She should pick up an instrument.
- I, I think there's like
an attack on free speech.
I mean, the stage is sacred.
I should be able to say what I wanna say
up here on stage.
I'm doing standup.
You know what you paid to come see.
- Right.
- You knew that before
you came in the building.
Why are you gonna attack me?
So when Will Smith smacked Chris,
I was hurt.
Not just to see a black
man smack another black man
on the biggest stage in the world.
- [Hillary] Right. Right.
- But that he opened the
door for people to think,
"Oh, if I say something about your wife,
you could come up here and assault me."
You can't do that.
You couldn't do that to Richard Pryor
or George Carlin.
- Yeah. Yeah.
(audience clapping)
- It's just jokes.
- Yeah. You know, Chelsea
and I did a series about gutsy women.
It's called "Gutsy".
It's gonna premiere in September
on "Apple TV Plus".
And we interviewed women comics
and we did that in part
because some people still
say women can't be funny.
And frankly, I disagree.
- Marsha Warfield?
- Are you kidding?
And we interviewed Wanda Sykes,
who was telling us,
who I adore, we interviewed her
and she was telling us
about how she'd gone
to a big comedy event
that was to raise money
for cancer.
So, I mean, it was a charitable event
but she and a bunch of
comics were doing it.
And she was the only woman.
And they were in Boston, I think.
And she had some jokes about politicians
who shall remain nameless.
And so she had these jokes,
half the audience laughed
and half the audience booed.
But the other men who'd been on the stage
had also had political jokes.
- Yeah.
- And people either
laughed or they didn't,
but they didn't boo.
And Wanda was saying like,
"You know, here I am, right.
I'm out there.
I'm telling these jokes.
And I'm a woman telling these jokes.
And somehow that produces the boos."
I thought that was really interesting.
- And for your daughter, that's my thing.
Like for my daughter, for your kids,
I want a better world.
I don't want women to
have to keep dancing.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, I don't wanna dance around it.
You should be able to
be bold and courageous
and funny and--
- The female soccer team.
- [Chelsea] Yes they're much better
than our men.
- I said,
then give them their money.
- Yes. Give them their money.
(audience cheering)
- [Tracy] Give them their money!
- All right, we have
to take another break.
Tickets for Tracy's "No
Disrespect" tour on sale right now,
Y'all go online to get yours.